so what do you do
as you make these decisions in your life
what platforms will i be on how much
will i engage with the con the people
who are always lying because ultimately
the people who are always lying it's
like they've got all of this energy here
in their whirlwind of lies and the more
that i go in yeah maybe every now and
again i can pull someone out of the
whirlwind and get them out but most
likely i'll just be sucked into the
cyclone and part of the destruction so
what do you do
you fight them and expose them on your
terms your terms that's the key to this
so here is the woman who i believe is
going to be the next governor of arizona
i've had her on the show carrie lake she
is a fantastic fighter of freedom uh
watch what she did to a cnn reporter a
couple days ago
hi harry hi nice to meet you
you don't have a mask on anymore let's
go outside
well we're six feet apart do you have a
minute to chat um i'll do an interview
okay as long as it airs on cnn plus does
it still exist i didn't think so because
the people don't like what you guys are
peddling which is propaganda thank you
you go girl as they say i'm not a
biologist but you go girl yeah that's
perfect you you destroy them to their
faces
300 million dollars that is how much
money cnn put into cnn plus and it
failed within a month do you know how
much money we've put into advertising on
this show
zero
white supremacist zero dollars we've
done this all on
i don't know putting out decent content
working with good people busting our
butts trying to do something that's real
and honest and then hopefully you guys
share it and spread the word and come to
shows and buy books or whatever it might
be that's what we've done and no matter
how much money they pump into their
lives people know the lies i believe we
have something internal in us that that
knows what time it is and sometimes you
can get confused and sometimes they can
spin the clock so you really have no
idea but at the end of the day i believe
that the truth prevails so i'll figure
out what i'm going to do on the on the
personal side of this but i think you
have to figure out what you want to do
related to all of this and and how
you're going to go forward with all of
this